[Musique]
je vous présente les participants
caroline précis des bons soirs vous êtes
chercheur au cnrs en as trop chimie vous
êtes au latmos et vous vous intéressez à
reconstituer
s'il y en a une une vie ailleurs est ce
que est ce qu'il ya des vies dans
d'autres planètes que que la nôtre et
peut-être même dans des exoplanètes
diraient les planètes qui soit
extrêmement loin qu'ils ne sont pas dans
le système solaire
phillip k dessus vous êtes le directeur
du latmos vous êtes aussi physicien et
vous nous expliquerez l'importance au
fond parce que au fond le le spatial en
france est atteint c'est vous vous
demande pas un français xavier bellamy
vous êtes philosophe vous êtes normalien
vous êtes l'auteur d'un livre qui fait
beaucoup de bruit qui est un best-seller
qui s'appelle le demeure jolie phrase
que j'ai lu dans le figaro un manifeste
pour les droits de l'homme
je crois que c'est un après de les
intrigues dit ça résume bien le votre
travail et puis pascal picq vous êtes
paléoanthropologue vous ajoutez même
paléoanthropologue évolutionniste et
vous êtes maître de conférences au
collège de france et puis votre dernier
livre qui est aux éditions alary
s'appelle le nouvel âge de l'humanité
des défis du transhumanisme expliquer
une lycéenne expliquer une lycéenne en
effet parce que c'est un dialogue avec
une lycéenne et qui vient d'afrique et
c'est comme ça un dialogue entre
l'origine de l'humanité et puis
peut-être le devenir de l'humanité
elle s'appelle à damas c'est une
référence et un philosophe
vous connaissez adamou le philosophe
adamou c'est pas le chanteur s'est pas
vous permettez monsieur non c'est un
philosophe noir du xviiie à 7 ans
c'est un philosophe qui était donc le
premier à obtenir un doctorat en
philosophie d'une grande université donc
en allemagne à la fin du 18ème siècle et
il a été d'être inquiète et construit
une partie de la tradition cartésienne
et cet homme donc a eu beaucoup de
succès parce qu'il est parti en afrique
pour essayer de développer
l'enseignement mais là c'est un peu plus
difficile époque mais ya deux
personnages comme cette époque là qui
était d'origine africaine et qui étaient
noirs étaient donc adamo et un autre
était donc un genre était un événement
sonel de mozart mais voilà qui était en
visite
mais au cp la tradition universitaire a
tendance à évacuer les gens de couleur
de la tradition universitaire la même
façon dont les technologies on évacue
les femmes temps classée encore en
travers a des conséquences considérables
quand même on va parler justement
d'humanisme et peut-être une question
d'actualité vous avez une vie qu'on
vient d'annoncer la naissance en chine
dvb génétiquement modifiés ils n'auront
pas paraît-il de sida blanc mais il
n'avait pas on les souhaite de quelque
chose qu'ils n'ont pas encore b est ce
que vous faites est ce qu'on est déjà
entrés dans un nouveau mandat dans un
autre monde
on est en train de voir se dessiner sous
nos yeux en tous les cas les grands
enjeux auxquels nous allons être
confrontés dans les années qui viennent
dans les décennies qui viennent et je
crois que l'exemple que vous évoquez à
l'instant nous permet tout de suite de
poser l'un des termes du problème
considérable qui est ici sous nos yeux
la question est précisément qu'il s'agit
d'un monde
je veux dire par là que nous sommes tous
reliés
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité que toute l'humanité porte
en même temps une responsabilité
collective
ce que nous avons déjà vu avec notre
rapport à la nature avec l'environnement
c'est à dire la nature en dehors de nous
pour la première fois il ya une
responsabilité globale qui se fait jour
dans la conscience humaine jusque là
jacques et à chaque nation pouvait faire
du bien ou du mal
sa mesure maintenant nous voyons que
nous sommes collectivement engagés ça
pose un problème absolument énorme de
responsabilité politique parce que on le
voit dans le débat aujourd'hui sur le
carburant beaucoup disent mais attendez
nous on peut bien réduire notre
consommation mais si d'autres que nous
continue de jouer les mêmes types de
deux manières de consommer de vivre de
travailler qui ont abîmé la planète
qu'est ce que ça va changer et bien de
la même façon nous sommes aussi devant
une responsabilité globale sur la
question de l'avenir de la nature cette
fois ci non plus à l'extérieur de nous
mais de la condition humaine elle-même
de notre propre condition et on voit
bien que de fait d'autres pays que le
nôtre ont pris une longueur d'avancé
dans des techniques qui ont pour but non
pas seulement de réparer lui maintenant
préserver fier la condition humaine mais
de le modifier de l'augmenter et c'est
le cas de la de la technique génétique
qui est actuellement mise en oeuvre en
chine on sait que les chinois sont très
en pointe sur cette question et on le
sujet se pose de notre être au monde en
quelque sorte est de notre
responsabilité à l'égard de l'avenir on
voit l'évoqué potable pascal picq vous
étudiez loeb alors depuis ses origines
alors opposé au delà des quelques
chiffres 1 l'homo erectus et 2 millions
d'années l'homo sapiens qui nous devrons
c'est à peu près 350 150 millions est-ce
que c'était comme des données très long
pour 20 avant que ça évolue
est ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui tout s'accélère et d'une
manière vertigineuse dans le problème
physique
dès qu'on parle d'évolution on parle de
paléontologie dont c'était déjà un grand
sujet qui est fascinant donc la
paléoanthropologie qui s'occupe de
l'évolution biologique de l'homme donc
essentiellement les fossiles mais dès
qu'on arrive dans des périodes plus
récentes
puis remonte maintenant jacques à 150
mille ans on dispose de l'adn donc on
parle maintenant de paléo génétique puis
aussi une idée de l'évolution et
consiste à croire que c'était une espèce
de long fleuve tranquille
bon ça va tranquillement ses progressive
c'est cumulatif
non ça s'appelle la théorie des
équilibres ponctué c'est à dire que
l'évolution de toutes les espèces
procèdent par des périodes de relative
stabilité des périodes aussi de open ya
deux jeux pas tape de progrès en tout
cas d'optimisation des adaptations et
puis des périodes de changement est
extrêmement rapide
alors pour la période aujourd'hui ça
vient des dix effectivement c'est la
première fois que nous sommes depuis le
début de l'an 2000 tous complètement
connecté du picard et le rêve le web
point de le pointer 02.01 nouvel âge de
l'humanité a demandé commencé en 2007
pour trois raisons la première c'est que
depuis 2007 la majorité la population
humaine devient organisé et sera de plus
en plus urbanisée deuxièmement c'est
l'arrivée du smartphone qui fait que
depuis ce matin nous tous nous avons
produit des centaines et des centaines
de tenez et ça c'est moins connu c'est
l'éclatement de ce qu'on appelle
l'intelligence artificielle en tout cas
celle qui est basée sur l'analyse de
route de deux je vais pas le dire
le système neurones artificiels avec des
algorithmes particulier qui est en train
d'éclater complètement aujourd'hui et ça
c'est en train de changer le monde
allait à toute vitesse puisqu'il ya les
californiens il y a donc les chinois qui
sont très très en avance aussi sur ces
questions là les géants chinoises ont
tellement hallucinant mais n'oublie sera
l os mobile canada 2 bis les russes qui
eux sont plutôt liées à l'armée et puis
là on vient sortir donc le plan vous
savez intelligence artificielle et il
est vrai que nous sommes un petit peu en
retard
la chose étant ça c'est tout à fait
nouveau c'est mehdi pas monsieur bel ami
mais moi je rappeler quand même
rapidement ce qui a été ma génération en
1964 est sorti du même conseil des
ministres le tgv est un but similaire
quatre ans plus tard ces mêmes 68 et
après c'est l'élection de monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing
la france a basculé de la modernité en
tous sens mais là ça concernait
effectivement les pays d'europe
occidentale
l'amérique du nord et le japon
aujourd'hui il est vrai que ça bouge
extrêmement vite mais il n'y a pas les
problèmes qui ont été soulevés c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya de vrais enjeux en
termes de démographie en termes
d'environnement et en terme est
effectivement de santé puisque les
biodiversité aussi s'écroule donc ce que
j'ai connu moi quand j'étais jeune
conscience de l'époque bien évidemment
mais tout ça se met tous à souvret soins
d'avenir qui était prometteur enfin tu
restes ici aujourd'hui
yahia c3 tous ces facteurs qui
interviennent et sur la transformation
possible de la vie qui pose de réels
problèmes d'éthique jeux d'hiver vous
êtes d'une génération qui a gagné une
vingtaine d'années d'espérance de vie
par exemple mais personne n'avait vu à
venir un camp a été inventé la retraite
par répartition ce qui au passage est
quand même une très belle idée de mettre
en place une solidarité
intergénérationnelle
mais personne n'avait imaginé que une
génération allait gagner 25 ans
d'espérance de vie et ça c'est une leçon
l'évolution l'évolution c'est toujours
des compromis
oui il ya des choses qu'on gagne puis
des choses auxquelles on s'est trompé
par un dont on se passerait bien je vous
la corde mais en tout cas c'est toujours
comme ça c'est pour ça qu'il est
toujours évolution l'un d'eux tous dans
la salle au moment nous sommes là où
regarder votre montre nous sommes face à
un monde qui change dont nous sommes les
principaux acteurs aujourd'hui au
passage c'est pas comme les dinosaures
qui ont récupéré un météorite
nous sommes la principale force qui
change le monde aujourd'hui sur cette
terre et ça c'est une chose qu'on a du
mal à comprendre
vous avez eu l'amabilité de rappeler
qu'il travaillait beaucoup de monde
économique et social une demi heure je
reviens à saint quentin en yvelines pour
une grande entreprise de technologie
message
mais la chose étant ya une chose que
l'on comprend bien que des météorites
que des volcans des tremblements de
terre que des changements courant c'est
annick pour parler de films donc le jour
d'après jurassic park etc puissent
modifier l'histoire de la vie mais ça
fait pas l'adaptation aux assassins
halimi des espèces ou pas l'autre chose
est que on comprend bien que au sein des
écosystèmes il puisse y avoir de
nouveaux virus des espèces invasives des
bouleversements dans les communautés
écologiques ça on comprend bien par
contre quelque chose qu'on a du mal à
comprendre c'est que plus une espèce est
un succès plus à modifier
l'environnement dans lequel elles aient
du succès et plus elle devra s'adapter
aux conséquences de son succès et c'est
bien ce que nous vivons aujourd'hui
depuis depuis je suis né pardon je mets
pour 100 demandes mais simplement c'est
pour montrer quand même que saigner
rapide depuis que je suis née la
population mondiale été multiplié par
trois oui c'est ça qui est du changement
concernés et puis
il ya eu aussi une consommation
d'énergie comme jamais et c'est à dire
en moyenne on a multiplié par 100 avec
beaucoup disparités et bien sûr notre
consommation énergétique qui était
multiplié par plus de 300 voire 400
depuis une cinquantaine d'années est
donc aujourd'hui les conséquences sont
là c'est l'effondrement des biodiversité
marine et terrestre et le dérèglement
climatique avec un réchauffement global
varie beaucoup de disparités et beaucoup
de personnes aujourd'hui existe à waimes
et comment on va faire en 2050
lorsque nous avons neuf milliards
d'individus pour moi ce n'est pas le
père problème compères problème est à
faire c'est après parce que le
vieillissement de la population va faire
que le haut de la pyramide qui n'est
plus une pyramide à l'inversé va s'en
aller
et aujourd'hui regardez ce qui se passe
en chine ou ailleurs nous savons sept
ans pierrick ce que je vous dis mais
l'expérience nous montre en
anthropologie qu'à chaque fois qu'une
population voit sa natalité écroulé elle
ne revient jamais vers des politiques de
natalité en tout cas ils ont du mal à
refaire des enfants est une vraie
inquiétude il ya très peu de philosophes
par ailleurs c'est un philosophe
j'ai presque connaissait monsieur bel
ami qui s'appelle monsieur qi d'un
christian gaudin qui a écrit un très bon
livre il à l'université de clermont
ferrand il ya dizaine d'années il a dit
la fin de l'humanité et tacle le love
l'horizon 2050 nous effraie parce qu'il
ya plein déchéance réchauffement
climatique les transhumanistes peut-être
on en parlait mais c'est qu'après nous
sommes dans l'incertitude totale à
savoir si l'humanité sera capable
d'avoir assez de dynamique démographique
pour se soutenir dans le monde qui
suivra
oui la perspective de l'essence ne donne
est donc là effectivement c'est très
clair on parle le transhumanisme les
gourous du transhumanisme de trouver les
solutions en 2003-2004 et moi et puis
ces belles âmes et responsables
politiques et je crois aussi pas le vrai
enjeu c'est ça qui m'intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est que les changements
étaient excusés sont déjà en cours et
les dix ans qui viennent avant les
mirages possible du transhumanisme vont
être déterminants pour l'avenir de
l'humanité
quand vous avez commencé à chercher vous
intéresser à l'espace c'était un espace
plus réduit qu'aujourd'hui c'est lé là
aussi les choses ont changé consignes
humblement dans le départ sa part de
quelques-uns ses terres qu'aujourd'hui
sur cette question là en france on est
on est bien positionné avec des agences
spatiales donc on a parlé tout à l'heure
de la va parler avec que voilà le le
spatial en france et dans la région est
bien développé ce qu'il faut voir c'est
que il ya soixante ans c'est presque un
hasard si temps peut-être finalement il
ya quelqu'un qui se saisit des des
fameuses fusée véronique et et qui
commence à avoir l'idée de sonder sonder
l'atmosphère et c'est ça qui va
enchaîner et on derrière on va faire
finalement la fusée diamants et d'autres
choses donc finalement on s'aperçoit que
sur cet aspect là on descend un peu
d'échelle mais on s'aperçoit que la en
dans la géopolitique finalement ce qui
s'est passé en france et est presque le
fruit du hasard finalement sur cette
évolution et notre position très très
impliqué dans le spatial et puis après
l'aéronautique en fait dépens de
quelques-uns est en fait sur sur la
recherche et c'est aussi on en est
toujours là c'est à dire que finalement
cette chose fantastique mais finalement
il ya toujours finalement que des petits
groupes qui qui travaillent sur ces
questions là et le monde est petit dans
la recherche
donc voilà on dépend de quelques-uns qui
ont des idées qui vont les mettre en
oeuvre et le mettre en oeuvre un
français d'evp l'avait juste dans votre
livre montré combien les découvertes
scientifiques notamment à galileo
modifier complètement la conception de
la philosophie les concepts de l'homme
comment comment avec juste boss ces
découvertes qui s'accélère ce
transhumain 10 besoins dont on va parler
les gens qui disent le le l'enfant qui
va vivre milan est déjà né comment le
philosophe peut s'adapter à ce
changement justement vos quêtes du pdj
est homo pour qu'on arrête de ceux de se
mouvoir en tous sens et quand jusque on
regarde un petit peu les choses telles
qu'elles sont mais comment vous adaptez
justement ce changement incessant
est ce que le philosophe si ça pose un
problème vous êtes alors d'abord je suis
enseignant en philosophie mais je crois
qu'on est tous appelés à être un peu
philosophe le dire par là que le staff
j'aurais j'aurais bien j'aurais bien du
mal à me revendiquer de ce titre il ya
beaucoup de professeurs de philosophie
d'une sens pas du tout philosophe et
beaucoup de gens qui ne sont pas
professeur de philosophie
mais ce que je crois c'est que le rôle
principal de la philosophie c'est de
nous permettre de gagner de gagner une
forme de distance à l'égard de
l'immédiateté du temps de nous permettre
de prendre un peu de recul d'objectiver
ce qui se produit et surtout de
s'interroger le principal effort de la
philosophie c'est cet effort de
l'interrogation la vie bonne dit platon
c'est la vie interrogés et donc vivre
bien c'est s'interroger sur ce que nous
sommes en train de faire et j'observe
que l'époque que nous vivons est à la
fois incroyablement propice pour
l'activité philosophique et en même
temps elle est aussi très dangereuse
pour l'activité philosophie propice
parce que nous n'avons jamais eu autant
besoin de nous poser des questions sur
ce qui est en train de se produire ce
que nous avons la chance de faire
ensemble ce soir et nous sommes tous
ensemble en train de philosophie d'une
certaine manière c'est à dire de prendre
du recul d'essayer de comprendre ce qui
nous arrivait de nous demander surtout
qu'est ce qui là dedans est bon et
qu'est ce qui est juste et comment est
ce que nous devons orienter notre action
ensuite pour qu'elle soit vraiment
féconde
jamais nous n'avons autant eu besoin
peut-être et d'ailleurs nous sommes très
nombreux à le dire dans nos métiers dans
nos activités professionnelles dans nos
vies quotidiennes
nous sommes très nombreux à vivre de ce
que nous appelons parfois une quête de
sens un besoin de sens un besoin de
comprendre vers où nous nous dirigeons
parce que le monde change à toute
vitesse et que nous avons parfois le
sentiment de n'avoir plus vraiment la
main sur le mouvement de ce qui se
produit nous en sommes à la fois les
acteurs évidemment les acteurs
principaux
mais en même temps nous sommes aussi
passifs nous subissons ce qui arrive et
nous avons l'impression de ne pas
pouvoir vraiment orienté le mouvement de
nos propres vies jamais la période n'a
été plus fécondes jamais elle n'a été
plus périlleuses aussi parce que
précisément ce mouvement et
d'accélération du temps fait que nous
vivons dans une forme d'immédiateté qui
nous rend très difficile l'interrogation
est notamment l'interrogation critique
et j'observe ce que j'essayais de dire
dans demeure est une mesure que il est
devenu très difficile d'interroger
l'innovation la nouveauté
et nous sommes conduits à y consentir
comme si c'était comme si tout ce qui
est nouveau et est forcément un progrès
je crois que c'est comme si on n'avait
pas y résister et comme si souhaitez
vous appelez le même si la vie elle fr
sont écrits d' avance la loi de murphy
c'est ça c'est à dire qu'il ya une
technique où on va l'utiliser à ryan
murphy elle est très ambigu parce
qu'elle a deux aspects l'un d'eux même
plusieurs
qui dit que si ça doit arriver ça doit
arriver bien d'autres qui disent si ça
doit merdé savent a merdé donc excusé
pardonne cette trivialité
mais monsieur bel habit a lâché 2
mollahs qui sont vraiment importants
pour notre époque progrès et innovation
alors peut-être que j'aurais le temps
d'expliquer tout à l'heure mais nous
allons entrer dans un monde vraiment
darwinien comprise le quai quand même
darwin parce que là en france
elle a vraiment du mal à compenser ce
que c'est que la pensée évolutionniste
mais très clairement ça veut dire quoi
c'est que les innovations on dit qu'il
faut innover pour continuer à rester à
sa place ça vient des ouïes scarole ça
ça s'appelle la reine rouge
il faut courir le plus vite possible
pour rester à sa place ça c'était propre
et imaginaire sauf que maintenant c'est
sur la terre et c'est maintenant et en
gros c'est très intéressant c'est mon
ami etienne klein qui malgré mon
attention là dessus une étude a été
faite par un sociologue monsieur bronner
qui montrent que depuis quelques années
la fréquence du terme progrès s'efface
devant l'augmentation de la fréquence du
terme l'innovation ce qui veut dire par
là c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans le monde
entier et des injonctions pour les
entreprises poussé par les gouvernements
pas la politique il faut innover pour
rester en avance pas sans savoir où on
va et on est complètement au déficit
d'une idée de devenir et les seuls qui
propose entre guillemets bien sûr une
possibilité de solution sur les
transhumanistes donc là voilà on est
quand même dans une situation son plan
philosophique extrêmement instable et
vit vraiment difficile qui fait que d'un
côté on l'a vu sans faire de politique
mais on a vu cette traduction dans les
élections récentes même en france
aujourd'hui face à ce monde qui change
tout le monde perçoit que ce monde
change mais vous avez une partie des
personnes qui pensent que l'avenir n'est
plus possible pour eux en tout cas ça va
être très difficile et d'autres qui
pensent que ça va être visible même sens
est facile et donc dans ce court n'est
complètement déficit aujourd'hui de
grandes idées de progrès qui pourrait
entraîner toute l'humanité
porter des choses la part des deux
fosses moins bien et voilà et très
clairement les grandes pensées du xxème
siècle de gauche et de droite
aujourd'hui on ça ce matin' encore bien
font plus tellement recettes on est bien
d'accord là dessus et nous cherchons le
monde de demain tout en sachant que nous
sommes nous mêmes en partie des acteurs
voient les situations qui requièrent de
l'éthique de la philosophie
l'anthropologie et de la science sans
que personne ne puisse se prétendent
avoir le la vision sur le monde qui
vient à part quelques hurluberlus mais
ça il a toujours parlé tout à l'heure de
ce qui s'est passé avant en chine c'est
une modification génétique cdu les en
péter les plombs la pardonnez moi parce
que le sida est un virus qu'on attrape
oui je ne connais pas de gènes contre le
sida
quelque chose complètement déments et
par ailleurs s'intégrant en jeu
aujourd'hui des tic
quand commence à transformer les génomes
on sait pas du tout ce qui va se passer
de génération en génération
pour une bonne raison vous avez que nous
savons est complaisamment de 10 en une
semaine mais ce complexe
ça joue la corde mais nous n'avons que
23 me gêne c'est rien du tout 23 me gêne
c'est rien du tout et tous ces jeunes
ont des interactions extrêmement
complexe donc c'est pas du legos un
génome
donc il ya quelques systèmes génétique
on sait qu'on peut changer de truites
chose des maladies qu'on appelle commet
malheureusement avant par les lapins
enfin pas malheureusement mais c'est
clair qu'on en parle mais pour ces
maladies donc génétique dont on parle
avec le téléthon donc là on est 10 ème
génétique qui sont assez bien ciblés
mais regardez il ya des efforts il ya
des recherches et les avancées
prodigieuse et on a quand même à peine
aujourd'hui quelque thérapie génétique
ils commencent à se prononcer non pas
que les chercheurs n'ont pas bien
chercher les chercheuses c'est que
masquer en aidant des systèmes
extrêmement complexe et de prétendre
changer un gène et résoudre le problème
c'est pas du lego est donc là on est
vraiment dans les responsabilités totale
et c'est évidemment l'ignorance totale
de ce que sont les sciences et la
biologie évolutionniste je vous
expliquais d'ailleurs très bien c'est
que l'évolution elle nécessite qui est
de la diversité c'est que si on crée
parce qu'il ya storella quand même c'est
de créer les mêmes hommes partout avec
la même route est le même cerveau
très intelligent etc mais du coup la
diversité on perd la diversité si on
perd la diversité on parle évolution au
risque de basculer dans un monde post
darwinien on n'aura jamais connu et dont
les modalités de changement peut pas
parler d'évolutions du coup ne sont
absolument même pas imaginer soyons très
clairs
donc il va falloir qu'on est cette
fois-ci véritable philosophie du
principe de précaution qui pour
l'instant n'est pas très bien appliqué
semble-t-il mais dans un sens ni dans
l'autre
enfin ça s'est fait à nos débats mais il
ya une certaine forme d'inconscience
ce sont des démurger du bricolage et de
10 n'a aucune valeur scientifique ça a
été dit mais qui comporte des risques
qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas du tout du
tout envisagé cet accord peut même pas
discuter sur ce qui va se passer on ne
sait évidemment complètement ouvert et
ignorée voilà les uns c'est parler des
transhumanistes et karine facile et
est-ce que par vrai est-ce que parfois
la science veut peur que vous avez peur
de vos recherches web
c'est une grande question après ce que
vous allez trouver peut être après non
recherche en particulier non on n'a pas
peur la science en général elle peut
amener à beaucoup de dérives
c'est pas la science qui fait peur c'est
c'est comment les gens vont s'en servir
c'est plutôt ça le projet alors il ya un
débat puis à pouvoir parler un peu de
l'espace mais il ya débat que vous
abordez vous très bien dans votre livre
ils vous ont distingué trois humains 10
b est ce que vous dites le
transhumanisme dans le transit via
urbanisme et veut distinguer trois
humains disent valeur pour pour aller
pour aller vite je peux je peux résumer
ces liens qui considère que c'est un
autre c'est un progrès et qu'il faut que
le progrès soit soit partagé par tous
il ya deuxième m'a dit si vous appelez
le post humanisme l'homme évolué pour
qu'il évolue il faut l'aider c'est un
peu l'homme augmenté
et puis le troisième c'est celui qui
pose qu'au fond l'évolution c'est fini
et qu'il faut créer un
notre autre main notre un autre être
humain et 3 les trois des trois sortent
du v10 v selon l'humanisme qu'on va
choisir évidemment les perspectives sont
très différentes vous pensez que le
transhumanisme c'est un humanisme moi
j'ai tendance à penser que ce qu'est ce
que sur cet enjeu est effectivement
comme le disait pascal qui conte et on
est de toute façon dans une ferme de
flou parce que en réalité c'est une
promesse qui nous est faite sans qu'on
sache très bien exactement quel est son
contenu et de fait je ne crois je ne
crois pas qu'il faille prendre
nécessairement au sérieux la totalité
des des fantasmes qui se joue des sexes
est plus du fantasme
il me semble que dans tous les cas
d'éric derrière la projection du transit
main il y a plutôt une forme d'anti
humanisme je m'explique lorsqu'on
affirme que la condition humaine ne doit
plus être seulement réparer protéger
préserver par les techniques médicales
mais qu'elle doit être vaincu en quelque
sorte dans les limites qu'elle nous
impose alors en fait on dit que l'humain
lorsqu'il n'est pas encore augmenté nous
apparaît comme diminué et ce qui me
paraît le plus inquiétant il ya
évidemment les risques de d'incidence
négative de conséquences dramatiques ou
de catastrophe que nous pourrions
produire parce que nous ne savons pas à
quoi nous touchons exactement comme
lorsque nous sommes entrés dans des
écosystèmes complexes nous avons
perturbé déséquilibre que nous ne
soupçonnions pas nous sommes devenus par
le la force de notre technique d'un une
puissance extraordinaire mais nous ne
sommes même pas assez puissant pour
réparer ce que notre propre puissance a
détruit
donc il ya quelque chose comme une
limite qui devrait s'imposer à nous et
qui nous impose la prudence
mais le plus grave encore n'est même pas
seulement le risque du mauvais pronostic
ou le risque que la loi de murphy se
réalise dans ce cas-là de négatif le
plus grave serait que nous en venions à
vivre dans une forme de frustration
perpétuelle parce que derrière le
changement constant qui est promis par
la technique il n'ya pas seulement la
réalisation de l'homme 2.0 après l'homme
2.0 y aura l'homme 3.0 et puis l'homme
4.0 est au fond le danger c'est que nous
rapportions à notre propre condition
exactement comme nous nous rapportons
aujourd'hui à nos smartphones
rappelez-vous en 2007 si vous aviez le
le premier smartphone vous étiez le roi
du pétrole vous n'aviez absolument le
celui que tout le monde enviait
maintenant si vous vous promenez avec le
même téléphone l'air ridicule le look
est bien le danger c'est que le
darwinisme la compétition contemporaine
finissent par se jouer aussi sur le
terrain de nos propres records et que
effectivement si si nous rêvons de
l'homme 2.0 après nous nous projetterons
immédiatement notre bonheur dans le
suivant et dans celui d'après encore il
me semble qu'un véritable ses 120 il me
semble qu'un véritable humanisme
consiste peut-être habité de nouveau
notre condition humaine avec ses avec
ses limites bien sûr avec sa finitude
de fait la technique n'abolit pas les
limites elles les des places seulement
l'apparition du smartphone a permis de
vaincre certaines limites mais on a créé
de nouvelles neiges maniable
immédiatement avec votre iphone votre
employeur vous en veut et donc la tk une
sorte de secret par la technique des
plages les contraintes
il me semble que nous ferions mieux
d'habiter les contraintes de notre
condition plutôt que de tenter de
relever toujours à quelque chose d'autre
quelque chose de meilleur la société de
consommation qui a tout construit pour
répondre aux désirs ne nous a pas rendu
plus heureux on voit bien avec des
changements auxquels on ne lui ont pas
pensé qu'ils mettent en danger de
démocratie de liberté
j'ai évoqué deux auteurs quand même que
tout le monde connaît ont quasiment tout
le monde élus d'ailleurs il ya eu des
films qui sont aldous huxley d'un côté
donc le meilleur des dont le frère a
inventé le terme d'étrangers mais la
dette grecque serait mort vers ce que
vous disiez c'est vrai que le table
transhumanisme apparu en 1157 sous la
plume de julian huxley qui est de petite
finale devrait dalhousie et le grand
père est un homme simon génialissime et
qui était tam a succédé un des grands
amis darwin jambes et mes idées et
magnifique d'ailleurs au passage parce
que il est premier secrétaire général de
l'unesco
c'est aussi un très très grand
scientifique et le projet au départ et
celui ci c'est à dire et retrouve la
charte de l'unesco d'ailleurs c'est à
dire par les sciences l'éducation la
culture faire en sorte que la mini de
l'humanité accueillir plus de maturité
et donc et de sagesse et surtout par la
connaissance partir ensemble vers un
progrès partagé et l'idée de diane oxley
c'est de se dire que la nature nous a
certainement les quais des potentialités
qui jusqu'à présent n'ont pas été
exprimé par exemple espérance de vie ou
labos où le scandale des sports de vie
en bonne santé et les des magnifiques
donc la première idée au départ ce
n'était pas de dire on va dépasser les
limites que nous a donné la nature qu'on
connaissait pas d'ailleurs à l'époque ne
connais pas toutes d'ailleurs mérité de
se dire par l'éducation la politique la
médecine la science amener une plus
grande partie de la population vers cet
état là en gros c'est ce qui s'est passé
dans les pros dans les pays
occidentalisés en moyenne après une
guerre mondiale jusqu'à deux années 90
d'ailleurs on voit très bien d'un
cotation là d'une expérience de vie
menée par exemple du qi de la santé etc
sauf que aujourd'hui on assiste
malheureusement il va falloir qu'ils les
transhumanistes fasse vite
on insiste quand même avec détérioration
d'une partie de la population dans
chaque nuit d'ailleurs qui va assez vite
donc je pas plombé la soirée mais ça ne
va pas se voir donc c'est là que vient
le transhumanisme donc aujourd'hui
s'était repris notamment californie
c'est intéressant parce que pour eux
c'est limite on les connaît en tout cas
ils prétendent les connaître et on va
forcément être obligé d'avoir recours à
des artefacts a les moyens
technologiques pour les dépasser parce
que ça dépasse presque dégaine autre
nature et là où quelqu'un ça se raconte
évidemment qu'on connaît pas du tout et
voilà sens il peut arriver et elle a par
contre ce qui est intéressant c'est ce
débat transhumanistes ne tremble pas du
tout les populations et les peuples
d'asie d'asie orientale
parce que eux intégrer les technologies
dans leur monde notamment que les robots
ça ne pose aucun problème et les russes
par contre encore autre chose
eux c'est l'idée c'est un vieux trucs
qui traînent chez les russes de
transformer leur âme dans des robots
dans des machines dans des robes on
cible donc il ya plein de mouvements
comme ça qui sont dans le monde qui sont
de dsb éclatement des différentes tables
de transhumanisme et donner un second
smartphone regarder comme ça va ça va
extrêmement vite pour revenir à luz
oxley et george orwell 1984
ils se connaissaient bien et j'étais
très ami et il échangé des lettres et un
moment où l'un et l'autre se disait en
fait et la tyrannie la pire que nous
pourrions envisager pour monde qui vient
à savoir le monde consumériste dans
lesquelles les gens sont accrochés aux
publicités à la consommation ça c'est le
meilleur des mondes
ou le big brother c'est à dire une
entité savaient ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui on a les deux les gaffes à
californien nous met dans des états de
dépendance on n'est pas assez
raisonnable pour ne pas cesser pia cela
donc pas de dépendance immédiat qu'on
appelle les causes immédiates et les
chinois aujourd'hui vous avez cas pas un
chinois qui n'est pas doté numériquement
ils sont tous figés du mérite mais
aujourd'hui les deux en train d'arriver
oui avant l'arrivée du transhumanisme on
voit que personne n'avait envisagé
l'effet que news les fausses nouvelles
les deux à nos démocraties est ce que
c'est ce que vous voulez bien vous savez
ça fait que deux ans maintenant face à
commencer avant mais là c'est vraiment
éclaté avec monsieur trump est ce que
vous voudrez aussi très bien d'autres
dans votre livre je trouve que c'est une
réflexion extrêmement forte
c'est que au fond tout lé transit visite
qui essayait qu'ils veulent qui rêvent
de transformer l'homme
ils ne pensent qu'à l'homme il pense pas
au reste il pose pas et pense pas
tellement la nature n'a pas dû aux
algues abattant 17 star trek c'est à
dire qu'effectivement c'est cette
logique et non mais c'est la mairie
ces détails ont fait place terrible on
en californie m'annoncer l'espace et dès
le départ quand il ya eu le
transhumanisme et notamment chez des
russes d'ailleurs ç'a toujours été avec
la conquête spatiale
c'est à dire la terre ok pour l'éditeur
va on va aller plus loin les mêmes qui
investissent dans le transhumanisme qui
investissent aussi dans leur conquête
spatiale bien sûr et la demande par
exemple d'interdire bien sur wii donc
oui je fais tout ce que je voulais
rajouter c'est que des grands
changements c'est malgré tout le fait
qu' on assiste à des pans une planétaire
c'est à dire que et ça ça a beaucoup
commençaient aussi avec la partie de
l'environnement
alors ça c'est vraiment déclenché
notamment alors même si ça peut sauver
un peu tout le monde au moment des des
problèmes de l'ozone stratosphérique
c'est à dire que c'est là vraiment on a
compris qu'on était capable d'envoyer un
autre poster des gaz à longue durée de
vie et qu'elle est du coup avoir un
effet global parce que même avant ça la
pollution reste et un fn local c'est
qu'on se disait bas chacun pollue dans
son coin
on va pas s'occuper du voisin et donc du
coup aujourd'hui les choses se
rejoignent entre les problèmes
effectivement
d'environnement et les problèmes de
communication qui vont chaque problème
chaque chaque évolution devient
planétaire c'est dire qu'aujourd'hui
même si quelqu'un dans son coin voulait
être à l'abri de tout ça il ne pourrait
pas donc ça c'est vraiment un changement
énorme parce que avant on avait quand
même cette chance ça sert possible si
vous voulez pas avancer avec le temps on
pouvait le faire aujourd'hui on pourra
trappe c'est à dire que personne et on
le voit bien on a cité aussi les gars
c'est à dire que du coup dans votre
activité de tous les jours on pouvait
pas de tranquille donc ça c'est quand
même un gros changement pour pour le
pour la décision individuelle malgré
tout pour ça qu'ils avaient les moyens
le titre d'un livre qui gros succès de
nos arrêts qui s'appelle homos des us
alors je sais pas s'il faut parler jeux
comme les philosophes du bri où vous
donne l'homme qui se prend pour dieu
évidemment c'est très inquiétant non ce
qui est très frappant c'est que ces
prêts anciens et très nouveau au fond le
le le les rêves qui s'exprime dans le
transhumanisme sont très anciens prenons
l'un d'entre eux par exemple la médecine
a toujours voulu tenter de préserver la
vie et donc de prolonger la vie
mais ici nous n'avons pas seulement
affaire à la réparation encore une fois
comme je le disais tout à l'heure nous
avons à faire à l'idée de changer au
génie de la nature et donc de vaincre la
mort l'idée de la mort de la mort est
l'une des dimensions du projet
transhumanistes c'est à dire l'idée d'un
homme qui ne soit pas seulement un homme
- malades en meilleure santé et qu'ils
vivent plus longtemps mais l'idée même
qu'il ne meurt plus du tout que sera
notre condition si nous ne mourons plus
d'abord il ya beaucoup de conséquences
qui sont évidemment immédiate la
première des conséquences c'est qu'il
faut surtout arrêter d'avoir des enfants
parce que sinon ça va très vite posé un
problème de place ou alors il va falloir
réparer rapidement un chemin vers mars
pour complice c'est vrai un peu mais
c'est vrai que le le projet
transhumanistes en soi reprend des rêves
très anciens dans demeure le site et ce
le plus ancien récits écrits conserver
de toute l'histoire de l'humanité qui
s'appelle l'épopée de gilgamesh
gilgamesh le grand homme qui ne voulait
pas mourir et donc c'est l'histoire d'un
roi le roi de la cité état de rock qui
traverse la totalité de la terre pour
trouver la plante qui rend immortel et
c'est pas c'est pas nouveau en fait
cette recherche ce qui est nouveau c'est
que pour la première fois il semble que
scientifiquement mais vous en saurez
plus que moi que les choses se
concrétisent alors maintenant nous
devons sans doute faire appel nous aussi
à ce qu'il ya de plus nouveau dans les
forces de la science mais en même temps
à ce qu'il ya de plus ancien dans la
sagesse de l'humanité pour pouvoir
tenter d'appréhender ce pouvoir qui se
dessine et ce pouvoir qui comme vous le
disiez à l'instant évidemment nous rend
tous solidaires parce que c'est
l'occasion d'une transformation globale
dont nous sommes tous participants car
l'une facile et vous êtes chercheuse au
cnrs et au latmos qui disait tout un oui
tous les patrons des gaffes à
s'intéresse à l'espace alors site de mal
mon but ce qui multiplie votre salaire
par discours pour aller chercher pour
lui vous lui dites quoi ben c'est pas
possible ça peut arriver ça pourrait
éventuellement arriver mais là on rentre
vraiment dans la dichotomie entre le
public et le privé où on fête le public
il va être gérée par l'état il n'a pas
du tout les mêmes contraintes que qu'un
privé qui est gérée par par lui-même
finalement et
et donc donc elon musk c'est à la fois
un moteur parce que c'est vrai que oui
il va il va pousser la compétition par
exemple l'homme sur mars basse et plus
uniquement la nasa et les autres à 16
ans agences spatiales
mais maintenant c'est également et
l'aude musk et le privé et donc on
accentue la compétition balle comme
quand on a eu la découverte ce point là
le génome le décryptage du génome humain
qui a été accentuée par la compétition
avec des gens de un peu plus mauvaises
intentions que que les universitaires et
donc donc en accélérant cette
compétition là là on est dans le côté
positif on fait du privé mais
malheureusement on a tous les côtés
négatifs qui vont être les les règles
qui sont imposés aux au public et qu'ils
ne sont pas au privé par exemple la nasa
qui vont envoyer un astronaute sur mars
elle est dans l'obligation de le ramener
au lendemain silva avait proposé un
envoi d'hommes à sens unique spécial il
peut très bien le faire et après on
ad'autres d'autres thématiques aussi
qu'ils sont un peu problématique pour le
pour le privé c'est là ce qu'on appelle
la protection planétaire c'est à dire
qu'on refuse de contaminer les autres
planètes
donc quand on envoie des missions sur
mars et sur sur n'importe quel corps du
système solaire
on est obligé de décontaminer tout ce
qu'on envoie pour éviter une
contamination par la vie terrestre ou
par par n'importe quoi qu'ils soient
terrestres en fait donc c'est une
une charte du cospar qui a été ratifié
par tous les pays qui participent à la
conquête spatiale
mais qui n'est malheureusement pas
appliquée au privé donc elon musk
il envoie une tesla dans l'espace sa
tesla n'est pas des contaminés si elle
s'écrase sur mars ils retournent sur sur
terre avec des bactéries qui ont évolué
dans les conditions spatiales qui sont
des conditions extrêmes parce qu'on a
des radiations on va participer une
évolution accélérée dans l'espace avec
d'autres convictions que celle qu'on
connaît sur terre la tesla qui est parti
dans l'espace est là elle avait des
bactéries à la pas été décontaminés
ces bactéries peut évoluer dans l'espace
un retour sur terre de la tesla peut
apporter des nouveaux des nouvelles
d'actifs de rio plus comprenait pas qui
pourrait éteindre toute forme de vie sur
terre ces extrêmes mais bon et est donc
quand on envoie des choses sur mars mais
on est obligé de les décontaminer il ya
des règles à respecter
elon musk ne doit pas les respecter ses
règlements les chartes sont en train
d'évoluer ça ne m'émeut pas été fait
pour la participation privée à la
conquête de l'espace
donc c'est un petit peu en retard là
dessus donc pour l'instant le privé
c'est bien ça accélère la compétition
mais c'est pas encore c'est pas encore
éthique comme l'est la recherche
publique sur la conquête spatiale
et c'est quand même une concentration
tout le monde était au dessus sur ce que
c'est pas forcément un philosophe qui
vous préférence mais que michel foucault
appeler le le pouvoir et le savoir ouais
mais on est quand même dans ce monde là
où le pouvoir a le savoir vous ensemble
et c'est ça pose quand même de l'argent
enfin et les moyens ça pose quand même
des problèmes non hospitalisés à temps
c'est de voir que il s'agisse des de ses
milliardaires d
l'entreprise numérique en californie et
même hugh jackman quand on connaît peu
souvent le nom pour ali baba mais
d'autres orgie tous ont fait fortune
dans les moyens de paiement en ligne
ils ont gagné des sommes extravagantes
et d'un seul coup sont complètement
investi dans une nouvelle technologie et
c'est complètement la bête ancien de
l'als venir ses intestins l'espace et
les nouvelles technologies la robotique
un médecine les projets de robotique ou
si elles sont vraiment paniquer donc
tout ça et non content de cela ils ont
complètement déjà déjà modifié toute
notre tissu socio économique les
entreprises aujourd'hui sont obligés
sont déjà complètement modifié par la
part ça dans deux jours je serai dans un
colloque dans le sud à monaco cplt wazi
d'un grand grand colloque avec avec des
responsables d'entreprises du monde
entier et puis des gens et là déjà
c'est peu de dire le monde va changer
c'est que déjà ça complètement changé et
c'est et en plus ça quelque chose qui
n'avait pas été prévu c'est à dire que
personne n'avait imaginé voir venir
hellodemain peter dille la voilà et
c'est ça qui nous surprend tous sont que
nous avons un débat parce que nous avons
une tradition sur l'éthique la
philosophie le progrès l'histoire d'un
monde occidental s'est fait que nous
posons des questions mais une fois de
plus j'ai aussi sur d'autres particules
ne s'oppose pas du tout cette question
là et ils avancent donc c'est pour ça
que ces grandes difficultés au niveau
international évidemment que d'avoir /
c# frissons internationale que vous
l'avez très bien si tu es aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas en tout cas pour les
principaux acteurs de vision partagée
aux minima éthique sur les changements
en cours
alors qu'arrive précis des tutelles est
ce que comme dans la chanson là vous
rêvez d'un autre mot de l'intérieur
est-ce que non mais vous recherchez en
effet la possibilité de vie ailleurs
vous avez beaucoup travaillé sur mars
je crois il avoue travailler aussi sur
des exoplanètes césar non moi je
travaille pas directement sur les
exoplanètes sont mes collègues qui
travaillent sur les exoplanètes moi je
reste dans le système solaire j'essaye
de concepts ne lâche rien c'est déjà
assez grand j'essaye de comprendre la
chimie du système solaire pour savoir
comment la chimie a peu évolué jusqu'à
la biologie donc donc en nous on a aussi
notre chaînon manquant en en exobiologie
c'est le passage de la chimie à la
biologie on sait que la chimie va
devenir de plus en plus complexes on
connaît ces processus donc
complexification à un moment il ya il ya
ce chaînon manquant et ensuite on passe
à la biologie
on sait pas comment on passe de la
chimie et la biologie donc en comprenant
jusqu'où la chimie peut aboutir en
complexité
on va et un nombre en recherchant cette
complexité chimiques dans le système
solaire on va essayer de comprendre
jusqu'à quel niveau de complexité elle
peut rester chimie et à partir de quel
niveau de complexité va passer biologie
donc biologiste à lire la vie dont vous
travaillez beaucoup avec des biologistes
évidemment donc je travaille avec les
biologistes je suis chimiste en fait
mais l'optimiste est donc l'exobiologie
c'est une thématique qui inclut vraiment
qui est vraiment au c'est la combinaison
de d'énormément de thématiques avec donc
tout ce qui est astrophysique biologie
chimie géologie et c'est donc ça c'est
sa force aussi à l'exobiologie c'est
cette interdisciplinarité et est donc en
comprenant la chimie dans le système
solaire et en recherchant en fait la
complexité chimique est également donc
les
les éventuelles traces de vie on va
essayer de mieux comprendre comment la
vie est apparue sur terre ah oui osons
qu on en revient à l'homme finalement au
dialogue mais quand on parle de vies
possible ailleurs là est ce que c'est
une vie comme bien d'autres je veux dire
est ce qu a cédé place d'auteuil à des
philosophes des paléoanthropologues est
ce que c'est juste des bactéries vague
possibilité de vie alors lorsqu'on ne
sait pas et là on ne sait pas c'est un
peu le grand paradoxe de discipline
c'est qu'on va rechercher quelque chose
qu'on sait même pas définir donc on va
rechercher la vie mais on sait pas
définir la vie dans le coeur la proche
peut sembler un peu un peu
anthropomorphique parce qu'on va se
baser sur ce qu'on connaît sur terre
pour aller rechercher dans le système
solaire est en fait c'est vraiment une
base parce qu'ils ont construit des
instruments cancan fabrique des
expériences et des instruments envoyé
dans le système solaire
ils sont tellement précis qu'il faut
rechercher quelque chose en particulier
on ne peut pas tirer dans le noir on
peut pas on peut pas aller dire bon on
va voir ce qu'il ya on est obligé de
l'irb on va rechercher si on trouve des
molécules carbonées et c'est donc on
doit on doit fabriquer des instruments
conceptualiser des instruments qui sont
basées sur une réalité vraiment
rechercher quelque chose de précis donc
on se base sur ce qu'on connaît qui est
la terre qui est la vie sur terre qui
est la seule vie qu'on connaisse
aujourd'hui et on va l'instant oui pour
l'instant on connaît pas d'autres on
n'en connaît pas de répit et va pas
d'autres mais on n'en connaît pas boire
on n'en connais aucune autre pour
l'instant et est donc à partir de la vie
sur terre on va chercher le dénominateur
commun a séduit et c'est ce qu'on va
appeler des bio signature agnostique
donc on va rechercher en fait c'est des
dénominateurs communs à la vie sur terre
qui pourrait des dénominateurs communs à
toute forme de vie qui existerait dans
le système solaire donc
donc on a quelques indices là tu sais
chimiques
encore une fois et donc cessons ces
vieux signature agnostique qu'on va
aller rechercher dans le système solaire
par par des sondes
on va envoyer sur différentes planètes
mars sur des satellites glacée de
jupiter et de saturne qui sont un petit
peu les cibles prioritaires de la nasa
en ce moment qui qui pourrait
éventuellement abriter une forme de vie
macroscopique dans des océans liquide
sous des couches de glace dans ses
satellites donc sur mars
on sait que la vie n'a pas pu dépasser
le stade bactérien si jamais elle a
existé
donc les martiens ça n'existe pas bah
des bactéries martial ça reste des
martiens mes petits hommes verts n'ont
fait sur mars ils auraient pas pu
dépasser le stade bactérien par contre
sur sur les autres corps du système
solaire d'intérêt pour l'exobiologie et
pour la recherche de vie on pourrait
éventuellement imaginer des poissons
dans les océans des de danser l'année
d'europe qui sont des satellites de
jupiter et de saturne avec un océan
d'eau liquide sous une couche de glace
pourquoi pas est ce que philippe que tu
te pourrir paieront aussi à cette
question est ce que des scientifiques
ont des souhaits c'est à dire est ce que
vous espérez qu'il est ce que ça vous
est égal parce que je pense que
globalement chacun sait assez sa vision
comme on dit du ahly à chacun sa
philosophie et c'est ce que je crois
c'est que c'est que le travail du
chercheur ces deux de tirer la pelote de
laine dire que on a un indice comme on
l'a dit on à une hypothèse et puis ont
tiré et on essaye de comprendre après
dans la dans la grande généralité
on n'est pas pour un endroit où un autre
ce qu'on veut c'est être certain d'où on
va saisir que on essaye d'accumuler des
preuves là quand on parle de ça ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que quand on fait
des observations c'est ce qu'on a dit on
cherche des choses extrêmement ténus
extrêmement faible avec l'instrument
extrêmement précis qui demandent un
traitement compliqué et c'est donc du
coup on est concentrés là-dessus ce dont
on est concentré sur avoir des indices
et on suit nos indices laissant sans
essayer à priori de laisser les choses
en disant les indices dans le monde
parle à moi on essaye de chergé de ce
qui concerne pas alors après c'est vrai
c'est cesser ce qui est vrai pour les
hôtes du gie est vrai pour les autres
sujets c'est un peu un puzzle qui est
toujours compliqué mais surtout on pas
en permanence de ce qu'on connaît c'est
à dire que on sait pas faire autre chose
on part de ce qu'on connaît et puis on
essaye de voir ce que connaît ou est ce
que ça marche pas et là si ça marche pas
ça veut dire qu'il ya salle il ya un
truc qu'on connaît pas donc ça peut être
intéressant mais c'est vrai qu'on a on a
quand même beaucoup de mal
intellectuellement à se dire je joue
bliss que je connais et je vais trèbes
et quelques chercher un truc qui ne
connaît pas on part quand même toujours
d'hypothèses
alors on est constamment en train de
faire une hypothèse de la valider ou de
l'invalidé et puis de rebondir sur autre
chose
donc c'est un jeu qui a impliqué un peu
long et 2 ont rebondi comme ça et puis
on dirait du modeste mais les choses
vont lentement alors voilà donné à voir
l'état vitesse sur la recherche ccd
poids quand même pas tout on a encore
notre tort mais est ce qu'on peut se
dire voilà dans tant d'années ou
d'ententes ans on saura s'il ya une vie
ou pas mais justement c'est intéressant
qu'une question parce que
des responsables de la nasa ont
récemment décrété qu'on trouvera la vie
dans le système solaire dans les dix
années qui viennent on aura des indices
de vie dans les dix années qui viennent
alors y'en a qui vont pouvoir dire bon
ben c'est pour récolter de l'argent pour
garder l'intérêt du public etc
mais en fait non c'est quand même basé
sur sur l'avancée de la science
aujourd'hui sur les priorités de la nasa
sur les futures missions dont on sait
maintenant que l'émission à la recherche
de vie dans le système solaire il y en a
eu une jusqu'à présent c'était vikings
sur mars en 1976 qui était même pas très
adapté parce qu'on en fait on
connaissait pas suffisamment le contexte
pour envoyer une mission pour rechercher
la ville mais ça a quand même été fait
les résultats ont été négatifs ce qui à
ce qui a plombé la recherche martienne
pendant une vingtaine d'années en fait
donc c'était finalement pas pas une très
bonne idée mais il ya eu il ya eu
extrêmement peu de recherche de vie dans
le système solaire
aujourd'hui une des priorités de la nasa
donc je dis nasa mais en fait la nasa
vu que c'est quand même le principal
contributeur de la recherche spatiale
c'est eux qui vont orienter les
recherches de toutes les agences
spatiales
mais quand je dis nasa ça inclut aussi
toutes les autres agences spatiales
mondiales y compris donc le cnes agence
spatiale française et les halles agence
spatiale européenne qui regroupe
plusieurs pays d'europe et est donc une
des priorités de la nasa maintenant
c'est de rechercher la vie chose qui n'a
pas été fait depuis
sur mars depuis 1976 et avec des moyens
qui sont et donc les donc aujourd'hui
qu'une des priorités c'est de rechercher
de la ville émissions vont être
voir pour objectif principal cette
recherche de traces de vie donc en la
recherchant bien entendu on a plus de
chance de la trouvais que sans la
rechercher
on a les technologiques ont également
énormément progresser maintenant on sait
comment elle recherchait ses traces
c'est bio signature agnostique par
exemple sur différentes planètes et donc
en fait tout ça mis ensemble les
avancées technologiques et les avancées
scientifiques qui ont été faites durant
c'est ses précédentes années qui ont qui
ont qui ont grandi vraiment de manière
exponentielle ces derniers temps ça nous
permet en fait d'avoir une évaluation de
s'il ya de la vie dans le système
solaire
on pourrait éventuellement l'a détecté
dans les dix années qui viennent pascal
picq ce dont rêvent de paléo
anthropologues vous dit peut-être qu'un
jour je vais les voir un homo erectus
qui sonne on aimerait bien je vais faire
une madame eric plus sérieusement c'est
très compliqué pour bien comprendre par
exemple notre domaine on a eu une
extraordinaire évolution des avancées
des connaissances grâce à la
paléogénétique il a même parlé et et
même la pâle ou linguistique c'est à
dire on compare les différents systèmes
génétiques entre langue et or on essaie
de regarder le caisson quand vous l'avez
très bien dit le l'ultime dénominateur
commun
donc c'est là qu'on a parlé de la langue
mère j'étais très à la mode ya une
vingtaine d'années dans mon domaine où
là aussi c'est un petit peu exagérer
quand même
delhaize lutte au coude rial des
mitochondries est en tête et en gagner
dans nos cellules qui ont leur propre
adn qui transmettent que de mère enfant
donc on reconstitue les lignées
maternelles et pour les hommes c'est le
chromosome
y mais même si nous trouvons l'ultime
briques commune à toutes les langues qui
peut nous connaissons aujourd'hui et
tout le système génétique humain
pourquoi nier aujourd'hui ça ne veut pas
dire que c'est le premier cela veut dire
que c'est le plus ancien dont nous avons
conservé la trace pour ça que ce travail
est extrêmement compliqué comme nous
d'ailleurs
maintenant on a vu beaucoup de choses
tout à l'heure pendant le concert à
propos donc des extraterrestres écoutez
il ya un truc moi qui me fais vraiment
me bidonner c'est que dans toutes lés
star trek et star war etc
ils ont tous des têtes et quand même pas
paisible mais ils sont tous bipèdes
comme nous oui et ça je peux vous dire
que la chercher bien loin la recherche
pas chercher il s'intéresse comme ça
mais c'est quand même absolument
ahurissant qu'on y pense parce que
évidemment c'est quasiment impossible
et pour vous dire la difficulté il faut
continuer ses recherches à s'avancer
très bien j'ai par exemple j'étais
récemment avec des gens comme francis
rocard
à propos de l'assaut qui vient d'arriver
sur mars est là et on a depuis longtemps
des radiotélescopes les est de détecter
des des émissions de radio des traces
d'extraterrestres
ça fait combien de temps que nous les
humains que les sons les ondes
électromagnétiques
ça fait un siècle à tout cas c'est ce
que représente quand même par rapport à
l'échelle de la vie sur la terre un cap
millionième de l'échelle de la vie sur
terre dont la probabilité que l'on
puisse trouver des gens des gens qui
marchent debout mais avec des têtes
complètement déglingué comme on voit
dans les films c'est déjà quasiment
impossible mais qui en plus ils sont 10
et envoyer un petit message radio ces
petits terriens qu'ils ont quand même
tout seul depuis un petit bout de temps
voilà donc ça veut dire que ça veut pas
dire pas de vie ailleurs c'est pas du
tout mon repos mec là aussi quand je
lisais le succès la conséquence de nos
évolutions moi des fois je suis effaré
je pense que c'est la même chose pour
vous quand les gens disent à la terre et
est parfaitement située pour que la vie
telle qu'on la paresse puisse émerger
comme cela mais pas du tout les
conditions initiales de l'apparition de
la vie sur terre n'ont rien à voir avec
celle que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
majorité largement modifié et même la
vie
à modifier l'atmosphère par exemple donc
c'est pour ça que ça montre bien que ces
recherches en est extraordinairement
compliquée mais ce qu'il ya eu donc
comme dans l'est alors ça comprend bien
pour les fossiles etc
mais ce sont des questions qui sont
exactement les mêmes dans tous nos
processus et d'une manière générale la
grande difficulté c'est que nous on peut
reconstituer l'ancêtre commun désormais
des chimpanzés par exemple parce que on
a déjà pensé mais eux ils n'ont pas leur
imposer de l'espace
c'est à dire qu'ils ont qu un seul
exemple donc c'est extrêmement mais on
va y arriver et monsieur toute façon je
vais y arriver mais justement un petit
commentaire par rapport à ces
technologies c'est qu'il ya un nouveau
moka paraît dans la discipline donc je
vous ai parlé des bio signature c'est
aller rechercher des traces d'une vie
donc par exemple dans le système solaire
selon moi je m'occupe après il ya donc
il ya un autre mot qui apparaît est de
plus en plus utilisé ce sont les technos
signature donc les technos signature ça
serait justement en fait d'aider des
messages donc principalement
électromagnétiques on imagine qu'ils
pourraient être reçus d'une civilisation
extraterrestre avancé donc là on parle
plus du système solaire là on parle des
exoplanètes et donc d'autres d'autres
d'autres galaxies mais on a quand même
cette grosse différence entre les bio
signature ou c'est nous qui allons
rechercher des traces
ou alors les technos signature où on
attend passivement que des
extraterrestres félix un beau quand même
sur le lac boss
des phillies et de doux et puis combien
de chercheurs quelle est l'importance
aussi de ce alors à toi nous nous la
particularité c'est que mon d'une part
on a été un petit peu au début de cette
aventure du spatial donc on a un certain
héritage
mais aujourd'hui notre intérêt par
rapport à ce débat c'est que c'est que
effectivement on se projette sur un
certain nombre de missions planétaire
pour aller explorer ces mondes mais on
travaille aussi beaucoup autour de la
terre et d'observation de la terre et du
coup on peut faire des allers retours
alors des allers-retours technologique
c'est à dire ce qu'on met au point pour
aller observer des choses sur terre dont
les utilisent pour pour les autres
planètes et vice versa mais aussi la
grande
la grande avancée c'est pouvoir
aujourd'hui tester des modèles
numériques de planètes qui sont extrêmes
c'est à dire que jusqu'à présent
finalement on avait une terre qui
présente une particularité qui sait
qu'elle est elle est assez stable alors
on s'offusque eu beaucoup quand il ya un
cyclone etc
ça fait des dégâts mais mais mais ça
reste malgré tout autour d'un point
médian qui est quand même assez faible
quand on va sur les autres planètes on a
des changements bien bien plus abrupte
que ça bien plus grand donc aujourd'hui
ce qui est intéressant pour nous c'est
effectivement de récolter des
informations sur les planètes pour
l'instant du système solaire pour
pouvoir finalement avoir un panorama de
notre connaissance qui dépasse un peu le
le système de notes de nos fameuses
moyenne climatique climatologiques et
météorologiques comme dont on parle tout
le temps on essaye toujours de regarder
par rapport à ce qu'on connaît comme
comme météo mais ça reste très stable
donc du coup ça c'est un intérêt d'aller
vous regardez des choses un peu plus
extrêmes donc nous c'est un petit peu ce
qu'on fait donc on développe beaucoup
d'instrumentation pour aller chercher
alors et on a des problématiques autant
sur terre que sur les planètes parce que
effectivement aujourd'hui encore il ya
beaucoup de choses qu'on ne connaît pas
de conte et objet de mesurer alors du
coup bien évidemment le flot de données
est très différent sur terre qu'il est
sur les sauts les autres planètes et du
coup on en a parlé tout à l'heure nous
aussi on est on est confronté à adapter
notre méthode aussi progressivement on
avait jusqu'à présent une technique qui
consistait à avoir des modèles physiques
au connaissait des équations de
thermodynamique que l'on connaissait et
donc du coup de confronter nos nos
observations ça aujourd'hui on va
progressivement aussi aller vers des
nouvelles technologies pour l'analyse
des mesures c'est à dire qu'on va et la
célérité finalement 6 il peut y avoir
des choses fiers de nos gars face à dire
qu'on va on va aller regarder les
données tous ensemble et finalement
sortir de ce nuage de données
finalement qu'est-ce qui nous apprend
sans présupposés donc ça ça change aussi
ça va changer progressivement les
approches des impôts
donc voilà donc donc nous on est on est
sur une continuité malgré tout puisque
finalement on a commencé il ya soixante
ans avec les diffuser ensuite des
ballons et puis ensuite au tour de la
terre et puis après dans les autre
planète
donc tout ça a progressé doucement avec
le fil conducteur de mieux caractériser
de mieux comprendre donc de le
laboratoire ccc 60 chercheurs
mais c'est aussi des équipes techniques
très importants qui mettent au point
justement les instruments et là on est
on est pas on parlait de l'espace
effectivement qui va c'est sûr qu'on
voit bien que payant une forte évolution
avec le privé qui va s'emparer de
l'espace parce que on est en train de
sortir finalement aussi progressivement
du domaine de recherche un peu inconnu
ça ça commençait du connu on parle de
déployer âge dans l'atmosphère on parle
de sortir et donc nous c'est pour ça que
finalement se déplace si notre on va
vers finalement les mondes inconnus
le système solaire et puis et puis a
progressivement se projette sur
existe-t-il d'autres mondes
et est ce qui pourrait potentiellement
abriter la vie
donc on a parlé des fameuses exemple est
donc en fait il ya un continuum et et
comme on l'a dit c'est qu'au départ on
s'est intéressé aux planètes leur
composition
on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait de l'ozone
qui avait de la vapeur d'eau dans
l'atmosphère et puis du coup maintenant
on en est au bio signature et est donc
on continue de tirer la pelote de laine
en essayant de comprendre finalement
commencé assez réagissez monde avec la
ja til en plus une vie au milieu ce qui
est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les
l'étude de la terre et de l'atmosphère
de la terre dans d autres thématiques du
latmos ça permet de participer à la
compréhension des atmosphères des autres
planètes et vice versa comprendre voire
analyser les autres planètes c'est aussi
comprendre la terre à différentes
époques
si on regarde
l'atmosphère de vénus ou deux
différentes planètes on peut comparer à
l'atmosphère de la terre primitive est
donc extrêmement différente de la terre
aujourd'hui tout change évidemment et et
comprendre ses atmosphères et ça ça va
donc nous donner des indices sur
l'atmosphère primitive de la terre et
comprendre comment la vie a pu évoluer
dans quelles conditions elle a évolué
sur terre françois-xavier bellamy opté
pour conclure là vous vous dites de
moeurs et des essais ce mouvement
perpétuel dit on pourrait lutter contre
contre lui mais phrase à dire qu est
très belle quand on parle du
transhumanisme c'est vrai qu'on
s'intéresse au corps de l'homme c'est
est ce qu'on va pouvoir malgré le chaos
et vous dites il ne suffit pas que le
corps soit à l'abri et l'âme aussi à ses
besoins est-ce que c'est pas ça aux
conclusions
vous pourrez donner à ces débats ce qui
est vrai c'est que c'est vraiment un
privilège de vous écouter j'étais
fasciné de ce que vous disiez du passage
de la chimie à la biologie
il ya comme ça des passages que la
science constate mais qui sont très
difficiles à comprendre pour nous le
passage de la matière inerte à la chimie
le passage de la physique et la chimie
de la chine et à la biologie puis il ya
un autre passage qui est celui de de la
biologie à la psychologie c'est à partir
de quand le phénomène de la conscience a
parait-il est là c'est pascal picq en
parlerait infiniment mieux que moi mais
on voit bien qu'il ya là quelque chose
qui fait que l'homme n'est pas tout à
fait un animal complètement comme les
autres les animaux évoluent et ils ont
été marqués par une évolution mais cette
évolution est très massivement subies
par cet animal dirait pascal krieg vous
direz c'est un animal
on attendait dans pardon j'ai déjà
interrompu excusez mon ski ce qui fait
que le les dinosaures ont disparu c'est
un accident qui leur est arrivé et nous
sommes par le fait de la conscience
capable de d'agir sur le monde qui nous
entoure d'une manière bien plus décisif
que tout le reste des animaux et il ya
là quelque chose qui évidemment marc la
singularité d'une dune psic et d'une âme
c'est le mot philosophique qui sait a
désigné cette conscience et la
conscience a besoin précisément non pas
d'arrêter le mouvement mais de pouvoir
le diriger nous ne sommes pas condamnés
à subir un mouvement qui nous emporte
je ne crois pas qu'il faille arrêter le
mouvement de l'histoire au contraire
notre défi pour nous aujourd'hui c'est
de réussir à remettre la main sur notre
propre pouvoir pour en faire l'occasion
un acte de liberté pour que nous
puissions dire voilà où nous voulons
aller
et aujourd'hui il semble que on parlait
tout à l'heure de la complexité infinie
que prend le la recherche scientifique
elle est aussi un vrai sujet pour la
politique au sens où tout à l'heure vous
posiez la question du savoir si elle
aime multiplier votre salaire par disque
est ce que vous allez faire mais c'est
un vrai sujet c'est à dire est ce que
nos états ont encore les moyens de
réguler l'activité d'une recherche qui
est devenu d'une complexité telle est ce
que nos états ont encore les moyens de
réguler l'activité des gaffes a alors
qu'elle a atteint un niveau de
sophistication ce qui sent capable de la
comprendre travaille précisément pour
les gaffes à et donc il ya il ya un sur
un sujet majeur dans notre liberté
collective
ces sujets qui nous attend et on voit
bien que le le fait de pouvoir faire en
sorte que ce qui compte pour nous
demeure que ce à quoi nous tenons que ce
qui fait la condition même de notre
survie demeure capable de perdurer que
le monde demeure vivable en quelque
sorte c'est l'un des plus grands enjeux
politiques qui nous attendent que le
monde demeure vivable et que l'homme
demeure humain et c'est un sujet
d'autant plus fort que je connaissais
déjà beaucoup de scénarios catastrophe
pour l'avenir de l'humanité
je viens de découvrir qu'il y en avait
un autre ce soir c'est à dire
l'irruption d'une tesla contaminée qui
pourraient tous nous faire mourir
avouez que ce serait quand même une
enfin pour l'aventuré humaine versé à
fibre vous du cerveau non juste un beau
nom mais ce qui est intéressant s'il ya
des disques effectivement plus que
jamais plus de tai ji dont vous avez
parlé des gars fabio s'il faut vraiment
parler aussi des bars de chinois puis
ils sont là c'est de là que viennent ces
découvertes un peu que troublante enfin
ça s'annonce en tout cas sur
manipulation du judo mais là c'est vrai
vous avez un petit peu évoquée taylor de
chardin tout à l'heure en filigrane est
délétère de chardin avait une espèce de
rêve à répéter celui du l'unité de
toutes les intelligences de la terre
avant tout des humains mais sur
émergents sur la conscience ça devient
très compliqué parce que vous savez on
se pose la question avec les
intelligences artificielles qui sont
déjà des mondes darwiniens qui évolue
par eux-mêmes s'appelle le fantôme de la
machine gosse et de la machine et et on
voit ça dans irobot et mon credo en ce
moment c'est de se dire si on n'est pas
capable de comprendre d intelligence et
sa tête forme de conscience autour de
nous notamment chez les grands singes
présente pas comme une autre évidemment
je crois qu'on va avoir des difficultés
à comprendre l'émergence des indigents
artificielle et donc il y en avoir une
réflexion sur ces mondes d'intelligence
de plus en plus connectés entre tous les
humains ce qui est en train de se faire
mais aussi avec les machines qui est en
train d'arriver et je pourrais pas faire
n'a plus beaucoup de retard avec les
autres espèces
et ce n'est capable d'arriver à cette
forme d'intelligence de nos sphères que
nous proposait alors de schaerbeek est
en train de se mettre en place cette
manière vous n'avez pas envisagé comme
ça évidemment là je pense
qu'effectivement on pas dit envisager un
avenir de l'humanité un peu plus entre
eux d'une manière un peu plus ce raid et
humaniste tout n'est pas perdu donc
merci a fini voilà c'est tout sauf si la
voiture dont nous parlait revient charge
l'aide de bactéries
merci infiniment karim précisé merci
infiniment philippe becker scut
françois-xavier bellamy et pascal picq
je signale que si vous voulez continuer
à réflexion parce que ces deux
réflexions
au fond votre livre d'abord une
réflexion assure le transit humanisme et
puis les possibilités qui nous offre
françois que j'avais bel ami et pascal
picq aux signes leurs livres à la sortie
de cette salle voilà donc ils vous
attendent et venez nombreux merci
infiniment à tous les quatre et merci à
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]